Today I'd like to tell you about a piece
of math known as holomorphic dynamics.
This is the field which studies things like the
Mandelbrot set, and in fact one of my main goals
today is to show you how this iconic shape, the
poster child of math, pops up in a more general
way than the initial definition might suggest.
This field is also intimately tied to what we
talked about in the last video with Newton's
fractal, and another goal of ours towards the
end of this video will be to help tie up
some of the loose ends that we had there.
So, first of all, this word "holomorphic" might
seem a little weird. It refers to functions that
have complex number inputs and complex number
outputs and which you can also take a derivative
of. Basically what it means to have a derivative
in this context is that when you zoom in to how
the function behaves near a given point, to
the point and its neighbors, it looks roughly
like scaling and rotating, like multiplying by
some complex constant. We'll talk more about
that in just a bit, but for now know that it
includes most of the ordinary functions that
you could write down, things like polynomials,
exponentials, trig functions, all of that.
The relevant dynamics in the title here comes from
asking what happens when you repeatedly apply one
of these functions over and over, in the sense of
evaluating on some input then evaluating the same
function on whatever you just got out, and then
doing that again and again and again and again.
Sometimes the pattern of points emerging
from this gets trapped in a cycle,
other times the sequence will just
approach some kind of limiting point.
Or maybe the sequence gets bigger and bigger and
it flies off to infinity, which mathematicians
also kind of think of as approaching a
limit point, just the "point at infinity".
And other times still they have no pattern
at all, and they behave chaotically.
What's surprising is that for all sorts
of functions that you might write down,
when you try to do something to visualize
when these different possible behaviors arise,
it often results in some insanely
intricate fractal pattern.
Those of you who watched the last video
have already seen one neat example of this.
There's this algorithm called Newton's method
which finds the root of some polynomial p,
and the way it works is to basically repeatedly
iterate the expression x -p(x)/p'(x), p' being
the derivative. When your initial seed value is in
the loose vicinity of a root to that polynomial,
a value where p(x)=0, this procedure
produces a sequence of values that
really quickly converges to that root. This is
what makes it a useful algorithm in practice.
But then we tried to do this in the complex
plane, looking at the many possible seed values
and asking which root in the complex plane
each one of these seed values might end up on,
then we associated a color with each one of the
roots and colored each pixel of the plane based
on which root a seed value starting at that pixel
would ultimately land on, the results we got were
some of these insanely intricate pictures with
these rough fractal boundaries between the colors.
In this example, if you look at the function
that we're actually iterating, say for some
specific choice of a polynomial like z^3 - 1, you
can rewrite the whole expression to look like one
polynomial divided by another. Mathematicians call
these kinds of functions "rational functions",
and if you forget the fact that
this arose from Newton's method,
you could reasonably ask what happens when
you iterate any other rational function.
In fact, this is exactly what the mathematicians
Piere Fatou and Gaston Julia did in the years
immediately following World War 1, and
they built up a surprisingly rich theory
of what happens when you iterate these rational
functions, which is particularly impressive given
that they had no computers to visualize
any of this the way that you and I can.
I think this distinguishes Julia as easily
being one of the greatest mathematicians of
all time who had no nose. Remember those
two names, they'll come up a bit later.
By far the most popularized example of a rational
function that you might study like this and the
fractals that can ensue is one of the simplest
functions, z^2 + c, where c is some constant.
I'm going to guess that this is at least somewhat
familiar to many of you but it certainly doesn't
hurt to quickly summarize the story here since
it can help set the stage for what comes later.
For this game, we're going to think of c as a
value that can be changed and it'll be visible
as this movable yellow dot. For the actual
iterative process, we will always start with
an initial value of z=0. So after iterating this
function once, doing z^2 + c, you get c. If you
iterate a second time, plugging in that value
to the function, you get c squared plus c. And
as I change around the value c here you can kind
of see how the second value moves in lockstep.
Then we can plug in that second value to
get z_3 and that third value to get z_4
and continue on like this
visualizing our chain of values.
If I keep doing this many different times for
the first many values, for some choices of c
this process remains bounded, you can still see
it all on the screen, and other times it looks
like it blows up. And you can actually show that
if it gets as big as 2, it'll blow up to infinity.
If you color the points of the plane where it
stays bounded black and you assign some other
gradient of colors to the divergent values based
on how quickly the process rushes off to infinity,
you get one of the most iconic images in all of
math, the Mandelbrot set. now this interactive
dots and stick visualization of the trajectory,
by the way, is heavily inspired by Ben Sparks'
illustration in the Numberphile video he did
about the Mandelbrot set, which is great,
you should watch it. I honestly thought it
was just too fun not to re-implement here.
I would also highly recommend the interactive
article on Acko.net about all of this stuff,
for any of you who haven't had
the pleasure of reading that yet.
What's nice about the Ben Sparks illustration
is how it illuminates what each different part
of the mandelbrot set actually represents. This
largest cardioid section includes the values of c
so that the process eventually converges
to some limit. The big circle on the left
represents the values where the process gets
trapped in a cycle between two values. And then
the top and bottom circles show values where the
process gets trapped in a cycle of three values,
and so on like this. Each one of these
little islands kind of has its own meaning.
Also notice, there is an important
difference between how this Mandelbrot set
and the Newton fractals we were
looking at before are each constructed,
beyond just a different underlying function.
For the mandelbrot set we have a consistent seed
value z=zero, but the thing we're tweaking is the
parameter c, changing the function itself. So
what you're looking at is what we might call
a "Parameter space". With Newton's fractal,
we have a single unchanging function,
but what we associate with each pixel is
a different seed value for the process.
Of course we could play the
same game with the map z^2 + c.
We could fix c at some constant and then let
the pixels represent the different possible
initial values z_0. Wo whereas each pixel of the
Mandelbrot set corresponds to a unique function,
the images on the right each just
correspond to a single function.
As we change the parameter c, it changes the
entire image on the right. And again, just to
be clear, the rule being applied is that we color
pixels black if the process remains bounded and
then apply some kind of gradient to the ones that
diverge away to infinity based on how quickly they
diverge to infinity. In principle, and it's kind
of mind-warping to think about, there is some
four-dimensional space of all combinations of
c and z_0, and what we're doing here is kind of
looking through individual two-dimensional slices
of that unimaginable pattern. You'll often hear or
read the images on the right being referred to
as "Julia sets" or "Julia fractals". And when I
first learned about all this stuff, I'll admit
that I kind of was left with the misconception
that this is what the term Julia set refers to,
specifically the z^2 + c case, and moreover that
it's referring to the black region on the inside.
However the term "Julia set" has a much more
general definition, and it would refer just to
the boundaries of these regions, not the interior.
To set the stage for a more specific
definition, and to also make some headway
towards the first goal that I mentioned at the
start, it's worth stepping back and really just
picturing yourself as a mathematician right
now discovering all of this. What would you
actually do to construct a theory around this?
It's one thing to look at some pretty pictures
but what sorts of questions would you ask
if you actually want to understand it all?
In general if you want to understand something
complicated, a good place to start is to ask if
there are any parts of the system that have some
simple behavior, preferably the simplest possible
behavior. In our example, that might mean asking
when does the process just stay fixed in place,
meaning f(z) = z. That's a pretty boring
set of dynamics, I think you'd agree.
We call a value with this property a "fixed
point" of the function. In the case of the
functions arising from Newton's method, by
design they have a fixed point at the roots
of the relevant polynomial. You can verify for
yourself if p(z) = 0, then the entire expression
is simply equal to z. That's what it means to be
a fixed point. If you're into exercises, you may
enjoy pausing for a moment and computing the fixed
points of this Mandelbrot set function, z^2 + c.
More generally, any rational function will
always have fixed points, since asking when this
expression equals z can always be rearranged as
finding the roots of some polynomial expression,
and from the fundamental theorem of
algebra this must have solutions,
typically as many solutions as the
highest degree in this expression.
Incidentally this means that you
could also find those fixed points
using Newton's method, but maybe that's
a little bit too meta for us right now.
Just asking about fixed points is maybe
easy, but a key idea for understanding
the full dynamics, and hence the
diagrams that we're looking at,
is to understand stability. We say
that a fixed point is attracting
if nearby points tend to get drawn in towards
it, and repelling if they're pushed away. And
this is something that you can actually compute
explicitly using the derivative of the function.
Symbolically, when you take derivatives
of complex functions, it looks exactly
the same as it would for real functions. So
something like z^2 has a derivative of 2z.
But geometrically there's a really lovely way to
interpret what this means. For example, at the
input 1 the derivative of this particular function
evaluates to be 2, and what that's telling us is
that if you look at a very small neighborhood
around that input and you follow what happens
to all the points in that little neighborhood
as you apply the function, in this case z^2,
then it looks just like you're multiplying
by 2. This is what a derivative of 2 means.
To take another example let's look at the input i.
We know that this function moves that input to the
value -1, that's i^2. But the added information
that its derivative at this value is 2 times i
gives us the added picture that when you zoom in
around that point and you look at the action of
the function on this tiny neighborhood, it looks
like multiplication by 2i, which in this case
is saying it looks like a 90 degree rotation
combined with a expansion by a factor of 2.
For the purposes of analyzing stability,
the only thing we care about here is the
growing and shrinking factor, the rotational part
doesn't matter. So if you compute the derivative
of a function at its fixed point, and the
absolute value of this result is less than one,
it tells you that the fixed point is attracting,
that nearby points tend to come in towards it.
If that derivative has an absolute
value bigger than one, it tells you
the fixed point is repelling,
it pushes away its neighbors.
For example if you work out the derivative of
our Newton's map expression, and you simplify
a couple things a little bit, here's what
you would get out. So if z is a fixed point,
which in this context means that it's
one of the roots of the polynomial p,
this derivative is not only smaller
than one, it's equal to zero.
These are sometimes called "superattracting" fixed
points, since it means that a neighborhood around
these points doesn't merely shrink, it shrinks
a lot. And again this is kind of by design,
since the intent of Newton's method is to produce
iterations that fall towards a root as quickly as
they can. Pulling up our z^2 + c, example if you
did the first exercise to find its fixed points,
the next step would be to ask when is at
least one of those fixed points is attracting.
For what values of c is this going to be true?
And then if that's not enough of a challenge,
try using the result that you find to show that
this condition corresponds to the main cardioid
shape of the Mandelbrot set. This is something
you can compute explicitly, it's pretty cool.
A natural next step would be to ask about cycles,
and this is where things really
start to get interesting.
If f(z) is not z, but some other value, and then
that value comes back to z, it means that you've
fallen into a two-cycle. You could explicitly
find these kinds of two-cycles by evaluating
f(f(z)), and then setting it equal to z.
For example with the z^2 + c map, f(f(z))
expands out to look like this. It's a little
messy, but you know it's not too terrible.
The main thing to highlight is that it boils
down to solving some degree four equation.
You should note though that the fixed points
will also be solutions to this equation,
so technically the two-cycles are the solutions
to this minus the solutions to the original fixed
point equation. And likewise you can use the same
idea to look for n-cycles by composing f with
itself n different times. The explicit expressions
that you would get quickly become insanely messy,
but it's still elucidating to ask how many cycles
would you expect based on this hypothetical
process. If we stick with our simple z^2 +
c example, as you compose it with itself you
get a polynomial with degree 4, and then one with
degree 8, and then degree 16, and so on and so on
exponentially growing the order of the polynomial.
So in principle, if I asked you how many cycles
are there with a period of one million, you
can know that it's equivalent to solving some
just absolutely insane polynomial expression
with a degree of 2 to the one million. So again,
fundamental theorem of algebra, you would expect
to find something on the order of 2 to the
one million points in the complex plane which
cycle in exactly this way. And more generally,
for any rational map, you'll always be able to
find values whose behavior falls into a cycle with
period n. It ultimately boils down to solving
some (probably insane) polynomial expression,
and just like with this example the number of such
periodic points will grow exponentially with n.
I didn't really talk about this in
the last video about newton's fractal,
but it's sort of strange to think that
there are infinitely many points that
fall into some kind of cycle
even for a process like this.
In almost all cases, though, these points
are somewhere on the boundary between those
colored regions and they don't really come up
in practice, because the probability of landing
on one of them is zero. What matters
for actually falling into one of these
is if one of the cycles is attracting, in
the sense that a neighborhood of points
around a value from that cycle would tend to
get pulled in towards that cycle. A highly
relevant question for someone interested
in numerical methods is whether or not this
Newton's map process ever has an attracting
cycle, because if there is, it means there's
a non-zero chance that your initial guess gets
trapped in that cycle and it never finds a root.
The answer here is actually yes! More explicitly
if you try to find the roots of z^3 - 2z + 2,
and you're using newton's method, watch what
happens to a small cluster that starts around
the value zero. It sort of bounces back and
forth, and... well...okay in this case the
cluster we started with was a little bit
too big, so some of the outer points get
sprayed away. But here's what it looks
like if we start with a smaller cluster.
Notice how all of the points genuinely do
shrink in towards the cycle between 0 and 1.
It's not likely that you hit this with a
random seed but it definitely is possible.
The exercise that you could do to verify that
a cycle like this is attracting, by the way,
would be to compute the derivative of f(f(z)), and
you check that at the input zero this derivative
has a magnitude less than one. The thing that
blew my mind a little is what happens when you
try to visualize which cubic polynomials have
attracting cycles at all. Hopefully, if Newton's
method is going to be at all decent at finding
roots, those attracting cycles should be rare.
First of all, to better visualize the one example
we're looking at, we could draw the same fractal
that we had before, coloring each point based on
what root the seed value starting at that point
will tend to, but this time we'll have an added
condition of coloring points that says that if
the seed value never gets close enough to a root
at all we will color the pixel black. Notice,
if I tweak the roots, meaning that we're
trying out different cubic polynomials,
it's actually really hard to find any place to
put them so that we see any black pixels at all.
I can find this one little sweet
spot here, but it's definitely rare.
Now what I want is some kind of way to visualize
every possible cubic polynomial at once with a
single image in a way that shows which ones have
attracting cycles. Luckily it turns out that there
is a really simple way to test whether or not
one of these polynomials has an attracting cycle.
All you have to do is look at the seed value
which sits at the average of the three roots,
this center of mass here. It turns
out, and this is not at all obvious,
if there's an attracting cycle, you can
guarantee that this seed value will fall into
that attracting cycle. In other words if there
are any black points, this will be one of them.
If you want to know where this magical fact
comes from, it stems from a theorem of our
good friend Fatou. He showed that if one of
these rational maps has an attracting cycle,
you can look at the values where the derivative of
your iterated function equals zero, and at least
one of those values has to fall into the cycle.
That might seem like a little bit of a weird fact,
but the loose intuition is that if a cycle is
going to be attracting, at least one of its values
should have a very small derivative, that's where
the shrinking will come from. And this in turn
means that that value in the cycle sits near some
point where the derivative is not merely small,
but equal to zero. And that point ends up being
close enough to get sucked into the cycle.
This fact also justifies why with the Mandelbrot
set, where we're only using one seed value z=0,
it's still enough to get us a very full
and interesting picture. If there's a
stable cycle to be found, that one seed
value is definitely going to find it.
I feel like maybe I'm assigning a little
too much homework and exercises today,
but if you're into that, yet another pleasing
one would be to look back at the derivative
expression that we found with our
function that arises from Newton's method
and use this wonderful theorem of Fatou's to
show our magical fact about cubic polynomials,
that it suffices to just check this midpoint
over the roots. Honestly, though, all of those
are details that you don't really have to worry
about. The upshot is that we can perform a test
for whether or not one of these polynomials has
an attracting cycle by looking at just a single
point, not all of them. And because of this,
we can actually generate a really cool diagram.
The way this will work is to fix two roots in
place, let's say putting them at z = -1 and z
= +1. And then we'll move around that third root,
which I'll call lambda. Remember, the key feature
that we're looking for is when the point at the
center of mass is black. So what I'll do is draw
a second diagram on the right where each pixel
corresponds to one possible choice of lambda.
What we're going to do is color that pixel based
on the color of this midpoint of the three roots.
If this feels a little bit confusing, that's
totally okay there are kind of a lot of layers at
play here. Just remember each pixel on the right
corresponds to a unique polynomial, as determined
by this parameter lambda. In fact you might
call this a "parameter space" sound familiar?
Points in this parameter space are colored black
if and only if the Newton's method process for the
corresponding polynomial produces an attracting
cycle. Again don't worry if that takes a little
moment to digest. At first glance, it might not
look like there are any black points at all on
this diagram. And this is good news! It means that
in most cases newton's method will not get sucked
into cycles like this. But, and I think I've
previewed this enough that you know exactly where
this is going, if we zoom in we can find a black
region, and that black region looks exactly like a
Mandelbrot set. Yet again, asking a question where
we tweak a parameter for one of these functions
yields this iconic cardioid and bubbles shape. The
upshot is that this shape is not as specific to
the z^2 + c example as you might think. It seems
to relate to something more general and universal
about parameter spaces with processes like this.
Still... one pressing question is why we get
fractals at all? In the last video I talked
about how the diagrams for Newton's method have
this very peculiar property where if you draw a
small circle around the boundary of a colored
region, that circle must actually include all
available colors from the picture. And this
is true more generally for any rational map,
if you were to assign colors to regions based on
which limiting behavior points fall into, like
which limit point or which limit cycle or does
it tend to infinity, then tiny circles that you
draw either contain points with just one of those
limiting behaviors, or they contain points with
all of them. It's never anything in between. So
in the case where there's at least three colors,
this property implies that our boundary could
never be smooth since along a smooth segment you
can draw a small enough circle that touches just
two colors, not all of them. And empirically this
is what we see. No matter how far you zoom in,
these boundaries are always rough, and furthermore
you might notice that as we zoom in you can
always see all available colors within the frame.
This doesn't explain rough boundaries in the
context where there's only two limiting behaviors,
but still it's a loose end that I
left in that video worth tying up,
and it's a nice excuse to bring in two important
bits of terminology: Julia sets and Fatou sets.
If a point eventually falls into
some stable predictable pattern,
we say that it's part of the Fatou set
of our iterated function. And for all
the maps that we've seen, this includes almost
everything. The julia set is everything else,
which in the pictures we've seen would be the
rough boundaries between the colored regions,
what happens as you transition from one stable
attractor to another. For example, the julia set
will include all of the repelling cycles and the
repelling fixed points. A typical point from the
julia set, though, will not be a cycle, it'll
bounce around forever with no clear pattern.
If you look at a point in the Fatou set
and you draw a small enough disk around it,
as you follow the process that small disk will
eventually shrink as you fall into whatever the
relevant stable behavior is. Unless you're going
to infinity, but you could kind of think of that
as the disc shrinking around infinity,
but maybe that just confuses matters...
By contrast if you draw a small disc around a
point on the Julia set, it tends to expand over
time as the points from within that circle
go off and kind of do their own things.
In other words, points of the Julia set tend
to behave chaotically. Their nearby neighbors,
even very nearby, will eventually fall
into qualitatively different behaviors.
But it's not merely that this disk
expands, a pretty surprising result,
key to the multi-color property mentioned
before, is that if you let this process play out
that little disk eventually expands so much that
it hits every single point on the complex plane,
with at most two exceptions. This is known as the
"stuff goes everywhere principle" of Julia sets.
Okay, it's not actually called that, in the
source I was reading from it's mentioned as
a corollary to something known as Montel's
theorem, but it should be called that. In
some sense what this is telling us is that the
points of the Julia set are not merely chaotic,
they're kind of as chaotic as they possibly can
be. Here let me show you a little simulation
using the newton's map with a
cluster of a few thousand points
all starting from within a tiny tiny distance
one one millionth from a point on the Julia set.
Of course the stuff goes everywhere principle
is about the uncountably infinitely many points
that would lie within that distance, and that
they eventually expand out to hit everything
on the plane, except possibly two points, but this
little cluster should still give the general idea.
A small finite sample from that tiny disk gets
sprayed all over the place in seemingly all
directions. What this means for our purposes
is that if there's some attractive behavior of
our map, something like an attracting
fixed point or an attracting cycle,
you can be guaranteed that the values from that
tiny disk around the point on the julia set
no matter how tiny it was will eventually
fall into that attracting behavior.
If we have a case with three or more
attracting behaviors this gives us
some explanation for why the Julia set is
not smooth, why it has to be complicated.
Even still this might not be entirely satisfying
because it kicks the can one more step down the
road, raising the question of why this "stuff goes
everywhere principle" is true in the first place.
Like I mentioned, it comes from something called
Montel's theorem, and I'm choosing not to go into
the details there, because honestly it's a lot to
cover. The proof I could find ends up leaning on
something known as the j-function which is a whole
intricate story in its own right, I will of course
leave links and resources in the description
for any of you who are hungry to learn more.
And if you know of a simpler way to see why this
principle is true I'm definitely all ears. I
should also say, as a brief side note, that even
though the pictures we've seen so far have a julia
set which has an area of zero, it's kind of the
boundary between these regions, there are examples
where the julia set is the entire plane everything
behaves chaotically, which is kind of wild.
The main takeaway for this particular
section is the link between the chaos
and the fractal. At first it seems like
these are merely analogous to each other.
You know Newton's method turns out to be a kind
of messy process for some seed values, and this
messiness is visible one way by following the
trajectory of a particular point, and another way
by the complexity of our diagrams. But those feel
like qualitatively different kinds of messiness,
maybe it makes for a nice metaphor but nothing
more. However what's neat here is that when you
quantify just how chaotic some of the points are
well that quantification leads us to an actual
explanation for the rough fractal shape via this
boundary property. Quite often you see chaos and
fractals sort of married together in math, and to
me at least it's satisfying whenever that marriage
comes with a logical link to it rather than as
two phenomena that just happened to coincide.